bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france oussama ben laden a été
tué est ce que finalement ça a été
vraiment un coup dur pour al-qaïda
alors oui ça a été un coup dur cette
période c'était il ya dix ans c'était en
mai 2011
je m'en souviens très bien gt gt en
libye à cette période et les libyens
étaient très tristes de la mort
d'oussama ben laden mais un chef a été
assassiné l'idéologie est toujours ici
est toujours présente et il a été
remplacé aussitôt par asa houari qui
était son numéro 2 qui est passé numéro
un qui est toujours recherché
al qaïda n'a pas pris un coup d'arrêt
parce que il sait bien restructurer
notamment en indonésie il est aux
présentes à l'insu arabique votre sujet
juste avant est très bien fait très
précis justement sur la liste des
personnes qui ont été abattus par les
l'école la commission je rajouterais le
fils d'oussama ben laden qui prenait un
petit peu plus un peu trop d'importance
et ils ont ils ont pas attendus avant
deux avant de le neutraliser pour qu'ils
prennent plus encore d'importance et
qu'il devienne encore plus un symbole
comme son père l'était al-qaïda
aujourd'hui fait partie d'un projet
islamiste qui a commencé en 1928 al
qaïda n'est pas inné doji al qaïda était
là pour imposer cette idéologie les de
logis samistes par des actions violentes
mais aussi par des par son idéologie par
des revendications religieuses dans
certains pays et en europe avant avant
l'arrivée de l'état islamique sa
technologie était très présente
j'ai travaillé sur des groupes en 1981
17 18 19 et 2000 qui est de mes seins
qui se revendiquait de cette idéologie
la proximité avec les balbutiements
d'al-qaïda l'époque alors les shebab en
somalie boko haram au nigeria dèche aqmi
au maghreb
quels sont les liens al qaïda en fait
les liens si vous voulez aujourd'hui il
y à peu près une vingtaine de groupes
islamistes armés dans le monde qui sont
capables d'imposer cette idéologie par
la violence et par aussi les les
revendications religieuses du quotidien
par l'idéologie oh oh je dirais
de chaque instant il ya à peu près une
vingtaine de groupes qui sont capables
de poser cette idéologie de façon locale
régionale nationale et internationale le
lien en fait c'est entre tous ces
groupes c'est c'est les frères musulmans
c'est le salafisme c'est cette idéologie
islamiste qui veut imposer leur islam en
occident donc oui il ya un lien entre
tous ces groupes et le lien n'est pas
forcément un homme ou un groupe parce
que les hommes les groupes passent mais
l'idéologie perdure et c'est bien
l'erreur que commettent qui ont commis
les occidentaux notamment les européens
et les français pensaient que parce que
l'état islamique et al-qaïda avait subi
des pertes notamment d'al khalis temps
dans les années 2000 quand les
américains sont intervenus avec la
coalition et la france n'ont al qaïda
n'est absolument pas détruit je dirais
de façon militaire de façon idéologique
encore moi parce qu'il s'est reconstitué
ailleurs on le retrouve bien évidemment
en afrique avec lui on le retrouve bien
évidemment amp et national a ravi que
l'on retrouve en l2 les i on le retrouve
un petit peu partout dans le monde et en
fait le dénominateur commun de tous ces
groupes là c'est l'islamisme c'est
l'idéologie islamiste qui a été on va
dire qui a été initiée par les frères
musulmans en 1928 et qui veut imposer la
charia sur la planète donc pour moi ben
laden et est passé al qaïda ou d'autres
groupes passeront aussi mais l'idéologie
islamiste perdurera finalement est-ce
que le 11 septembre a changé quelque
chose dans la manière de lutter contre
le terrorisme
oui madame considérablement le 11
septembre j'étais encore j'étais encore
au service action de la dgse et je me
souviens très bien je me suis posé une
question ou relire dans les tours tomber
mais à quoi à quoi sert ton et depuis ce
jour là il y a eu bien évidemment des
interventions qui ont stoppé les groupes
qui étaient en place à l'époque en
afghanistan qui a eu il ya eu 10 racks à
déstabiliser des régions ça encore plus
donner le sentiment à certains musulmans
extrémistes que
c'était l'islam qu'on attaque et que
l'occident attaquer l'islam donc il se
sent encore plus montés contre contre
l'occident les contrôles à canton la
manière de vivre des démocraties
occidentales est selon moi le 11
septembre a eu un effet dévastateur
parce que on s'est dit ils se sont vus
c'est possible d'attaquer là le symbole
des états unis en plein coeur de
manhattan
donc à partir de là il ya eu de cesse de
vouloir prospérer idéologiquement et de
façon violente sur sur l'occident le 11
septembre c'est un c'est un tournant il
ya eu 1 928 il y à 1979
cela va être la première république
islamique aussi qui a donné la
possibilité à cet islam rigoriste dur de
gouverner est d'être un pays de
totalitarisme comme comme les l'iran
actuellement et il ya aussi les sunnites
avec tout ce que tous les groupes
islamistes con qu'on a aujourd'hui de
par le monde le 11 septembre c'était un
vrai virage
pierre martinet merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien agent du service action de la
dgse mercier